because you are very tall i love your
trees
because they're so tall
man this is like i love your old gray
missions i love your vineyards
stretching
far i love you california with your
golden gate a jar
a jar jaw
slightly open it's open it doesn't open
it doesn't
like it's not like you can go under it
into the bay
the golden gate has been left to jar
that was like a colby song
like early 2000s yeah all these songs
across the country we need to update all
the state songs these are
not just like 1920s old-timey stuff
there's a video
we made state songs better than the u.s
government
we made the state songs songs trap
acoustic guitar riff though you have
your guitar plugged into your amp
no i just doesn't connect to an amp i
mean this is it
this is all it is right here this is
dirty jenny where do you put the
batteries
uh they go right in there is that guitar
correct
oh yeah oh that's why oh she's real beat
up
it's got special sounds that come out of
here see i repaired it
oh nice you're right it's not broken and
anymore my kit my kids put stickers on
it
i repaired it with uh with tiny nails
and wood glue but what happened to your
guitar jake
this guitar um when i was in college
uh i was in a band and we had a thing
about smashing guitars
because we thought it was cool so
this one one unlucky night i um
i smacked this one around a bit and uh
it actually didn't break so i
i kept it that's how i test my guitars
too smashing an acoustic guitar is kind
of lame though
like an electric guitar it's got like
it's loud and noisy when you smash it
but an acoustic one it's just like
i don't know yeah wasn't at a show or
anything we were just playing
and we were kind of we were kind of we
were we had been drinking and it was
like you know we were just hanging out
and playing music and stuff and
okay that's kind of cool though you're
not trying to show off to people
no yeah we never smashed them at shows
or anything
just kind of like i only smashed them
privately
yeah just to do it for myself
yeah um so that's that's what we were
doing
and then uh you know a couple years
later i fixed it
and uh you know i kind of like the sound
of it now i've grown attached
nice yeah uh i know we've been like this
podcast is like we're ten minutes in
already but will you play us a little
bit we're rolling
yeah we're rolling
[Music]
peter never knows when we're rolling i
don't
i don't the cameras could be on at any
time
they could peter never rose when we're
rolling i don't
i don't he turned around to see the
cameras were rolling
what what is that he came to the studio
[Music]
what what's he gonna do now
what's he gonna do now what do i do
[Laughter]
now what do we do i guess we talk about
things yeah this is actually the enter
that limb biscuit song keep rolling
yeah keep rolling
the chill country version is pretty cool
though yeah
we should do a chill country version of
keep rolling rolling rolling
all right i don't know the chords to
that song but
let's just use your mouse why don't we
just use your imaginations
keep rolling chord progression
just shout them out you guys had that
band what was the name of it
the keep the keep whatever happened give
me a couple chords
all right hold on hold on we we kind of
topped out pretty quick
we just were like hey this is fun and
then we gotta
biscuits keep rolling are we having two
conversations
and then so we had to get you she's good
podcast e
and c sharp g sharp five thousand people
that's basically
like wow that was dope and then c
sorry like we were playing music we
recorded like an ep
and we're like that was dope and then we
played a huge show and we're like that
was sweet and we're like cool
well what do you want to do now and
so we kind of moved on rolling rolling
rolling rolling
rolling kept rolling rolling rolling
all right so i actually have a question
about uh our song slow and reverse i
recorded way back in the day
okay in the mix you can't hear my bass
drum at all
is that because it actually was like
really janky and i was way off tune and
you guys just felt like not fixing it so
you mixed it down all the way
cause i remember taking like a three
hour nap and when you guys were doing
the mixing of my drum part
or is that just how it was mixed no
there was just how it was mixed
yeah there was no like hidden messaging
in there between us and alex i think he
just mixed it down
i'm just i was just like you know
because i was pretty fresh with the
drums still i'm just wondering it's like
was my baseline just really janky so
there's no savings
it's just one of those things where you
know he mixes it
and you know he kind of hands it over
it's kind of like cool
you know he's doing it's a freebie we
can't like we weren't we didn't push it
very hard
okay yeah i i don't know if it had to do
with like a
because it was kind of like progressive
metal or
so he mixed it down because of that or
if he was trying to
like bring up the the metallic side of
it i think
we should finally get the stems from him
he seems like the guy is organized
enough to have guys guys
10 years later we've remastered
our first album anyway sorry i'm sorry
anyone who
like masters professionally which it
seems like
that's what he was doing you you hang on
to those files
like that's kind of your it's kind of a
thing well i mean we don't hang on to
like other people's files for more than
a few years
we don't hang on to our own files
[Laughter]
just ask peter when he attempted to
remaster the uh glitch video oh geez
different one is audio though like you
can have 10 years of audio projects
on a hard drive that that's true it
takes like a year's
worth of our videos yeah that's true
speaking of remastering uh yeah we have
peter and i have been hard at work
at uh at something or the past when
you're here
very important something very important
very important work is going down at
corridor
yeah big things are coming yeah well
everybody's like you know what we're
none of us are satisfied with
our superman and batman action figures
anymore we want zack snyder
to show us how to play with them and
warner brothers decided to spend like
80 million dollars to uh put everything
back into four by three
aspect ratio uh well no they expanded it
that's expanded
we're getting extra frames they cgi at
the top and bottom of every single
that's how it was originally shot and
they and they brought back zack snyder's
original vision but you know what
joss whedon has made some great movies
in his day and uh
you know i think the fact that we're not
seeing his original vision of the
mustache
on superman is really just a travesty
and true
true fans should be clamoring for the
mustache cut
yep and uh the weed inverse the abuse of
whedon verse
[Laughter]
so apparently uh you know in order to
get everybody inspired because nobody
actually cares about the mustache cut at
the moment uh we
need to demonstrate just what could be
so peter and i have
spent the past uh week putting a
mustache back on superman yeah not that
anybody asked for it but
although people don't know they want it
so far what i've learned
is that the mustache cut is cool but the
soul patch cut is actually
truly the amazing piece of art that
really
does like instantly transform yeah henry
cavill with a soul patch
as superman we'll do that in pressure
we'll do that the follow-up will be the
mustache cut and then the soul patch cut
oh
jake we've already made the soul patch
cut my friend
[Laughter]
you did a sub cut within the mustache
cut yeah we did a little uh
we got the soul patch cut we got that
pencil we got the juicy lips cut
yep wow i wait so so walk me through
this peter you
you sat down what a week ago and you
were like okay
i got a bunch of footage in front of me
yeah what what do i do with it yeah so i
mean
usually with these videos it's like you
want an end goal to be striving towards
as you're doing these
wacky vfx and so i decided to go with
like a little trailer
for the mustache cut you know to get
people amped for that and uh
you know start the movement get people
out on the streets
and 70 million bucks exactly
justice league with him having a
mustache i didn't that's an even better
idea i didn't even think about that
but yeah i cut together a little trailer
uh with different footage from like all
the different zack snyder movies
uh telling story of superman losing his
mustache
and then i don't want to spoil it but he
gets it back yeah
it's epic spoiled in a big way
in a major way in a major way
yeah you've never seen anything like
this because i thought you guys were
just going to stop at
that but it sounds like you've gone
above and beyond
yeah well it's pretty goofy we uh so
there's a plugin for after effects
called lockdown which basically lets you
track something onto a surface really
really well
um like a distorting surface yeah like
previously was
not possible you put a logo on a shirt
for example as a shirt flaps in the wind
or the flag that slaps in the wind if
you will
add an extra start of the american flag
exactly
so dc
[Laughter]
so peter fired up a couple clips and ran
them through lockdown so all we had to
do was swap in
different mustaches at will and we could
preview them and what they would look
like
and that's how we arrived the soul patch
cut uh
and we realized that this is really this
is the true superman we've all been
waiting for
yeah i think we should change the
marketing for this video to
exclusively the soul patch how much have
you learned about
the the names for styles of mustaches
okay we actually have learned like
uh apparently okay okay let's just
let's see what jake says okay so jake
what is the handlebar mustache yeah show
us the shape with your fingers where's
the handlebar mustache
wrong
mustache like those motorcycles with the
really big handlebars
hangers right right that's the ape
hanger stash
it's so yeah what was it called
horseshoe horseshoe yeah
yeah horseshoe mustache shoe stash
horseshoe
it's a lot of stresses and this is
our favorite stash on henry cavill or
just in general no just like in general
yeah after all this education that
you've now gotten
the uh the real nice thing the snot brag
or whatever
the snot kicker the snot kicker that's
the one that uh charlie chaplin's like
hitler yeah charlie chaplin we called
charlie chaplin
wasn't it
never just never wear a mustache called
a snot anything
it's just the express lane from your
nose to your mouth
so yeah there's that style um all aboard
but honestly so the funny thing is like
break
it's not breaking that's it that's not
yeah yeah it's not breaking but
that's a hard mustache to do because
it's like
like most people have that little like
part you know
so you'd think that the big bushy
mustache is the most impressive but
actually it's the
it's not catcher it's not yeah what's
that called phylum or something yeah
the thing on your between yeah it
requires the most maintenance
the highest level of detail i mean you
have to be
real ballsy to try and pull off a snap
break in today's stage
oh yeah the point i don't think i mean
yeah
i think you might get cancelled yeah
that style was basically
put to rest in 1945 yeah chaplain shaved
it after that
oh really yeah he was like he did yeah
yeah he did
what is that there's like like there's
still people who are named adolf today
yeah yeah well it's a it's a pretty
sure yeah yeah i guess so
yeah so still people that are named jim
too
[Laughter]
um so we did discover while we were
putting the mustache back on superman
that superman with like a normal
mustache like just a normal like
uncle clark mustache like looks
not too bad yeah honestly so much more
inviting yeah way more inviting like
henry cavill
cavill sorry i always pronounce his last
name wrong henry cavill
like he's like intimidatingly handsome
and when you put a mustache on him he
becomes a little more approachable
like it's like a superman that you could
call on for help and you wouldn't be
like nervous to talk to him about like
that's what i'm gonna i'm gonna start
wearing a full mustache and when people
ask me why i'm gonna say because
people found i was too intimidatingly
handsome
now i'm more approachable this brings me
from a 10 to like an eighth
much easier to touch but in all honesty
i think
i do think warner brothers if they keep
using henry cavill should
consider actually putting a mustache on
absolutely yeah he just looks like a
freaking alien which i guess he is
as superman he is an alien he is
technically an alien yes
yeah he is an alien yeah i
i mean he has it in the old comics in
some of them doesn't he
right yeah well does superman having a
mustache in the old comics
yeah i mean sometimes we're talking
about how he has like a mustache or a
beard and he'll
in canon like use his laser eyes to
shave it off that's
right that's right yeah it's established
both in the cartoon and in the
lois and clark uh not to be confused
with the explorers lewis and clark
uh tv show is that good have you watched
that lois and clark
not really yeah it was on tv back when i
was like pretty young
and probably didn't care wait what have
you google there's a new one superman
mustache
it's all just pictures of henry cavill
with a mustache
no so
peter the technique like have you for
the shots that aren't using
well i guess i should probably talk
about the deep pick techniques instead
of using that for like a ton of the
shots
yeah so the the way we're approaching
doing the the mustache
uh because we we saw how janky it gets
when they take the mustache off of his
face
um rather than like having to sit there
and track every shot and like manipulate
a cg mustache onto him
we just used deep fakes we basically
just grabbed a bunch of footage from
mission impossible of henry cavill with
a mustache and then
trained a deep fake to draw his face
with the mustache
and put that onto his face that doesn't
have the mustache which
was actually relatively straightforward
because it's just putting the same
person's face
onto their face and it's kind of the
first test of this theory we've had
about how you could use deep fakes to
basically do makeup on people
like let's say somebody has a
complicated makeup system or like a
tattoo or something like that
or something else that's like you know
takes a couple hours to put on their
face theoretically
you could just put it on their face once
train it and then
let that be a thing to just use whenever
you need to do a makeup filter
can we remove mike tyson's face
tattoo i would need footage of him
without his face tattoo
no there's yeah there should be plenty
of that we'll just clone stamp it
ten thousand times ten thousand times
yeah
uh but the fight so the defect technique
actually worked really well yeah um
looks great
especially just like masking out the
mustache yeah because then you get to
keep all the high quality eyes and stuff
the only of course the only limitation
is
there's actually not a whole lot of
shots of henry cavill with the mustache
mission impossible and like there's a
lot of weird angles and weird
expressions from justice league that
we don't have data of of henry cavill's
face doing the same thing when he has a
mustache on
so every once in a while the shots get
kind of blurry and whatnot but for the
vast majority of them it's
a really convincing mustache filter it's
interesting though on
the janky replaced mouth shots you can
tell
what his mouth should have actually
looked like yeah
wait which is what they already had with
the original footage
yeah we discovered like you know
everybody knows how janky his face
looked when they
took the mustache off we discovered that
one of the issues was that they changed
the
height of his teeth like his teeth were
extended downwards
a little bit yeah like his gums got
stretched
yeah and it's really like once you start
flipping back and forth between the deep
fake which is like his actual face
structure
and like the weird cg
kind of effect or something yeah that's
what i definitely noticed too
they yeah they made his lip they made
this section
longer well then they they made the
teeth themselves like
lower on his face um it's hard to
describe without
showing the video if you guys if
everybody watches the the quarter crew
video going up this sunday they'll see
it
um but it's one of those like weird
little details that like
you need to be hyper aware of like the
nuances the nuances of what
gives somebody the likeness in their
face and like that gap between
your teeth where that gap sits relative
to your mouth when it's open
is like it's a very quick tell that your
brain uses to like get somebody's
face geometry but like in real life like
if you were to draw a picture of
somebody you wouldn't think about like
oh is the gap between their top and
bottom teeth the right height relative
to their lips being parted
like those details like totally escape
us
but you know we get to see it what it
should have actually been in the deep
fake
but yeah i kind of want to do like the
uh the deep fake makeup thing but i also
you were throwing i can't remember it
was you and matt and somebody else was
like throwing on this idea
of uh you train to train like so a deep
fake
is basically just a computer learning
what a face looks like and then
redrawing that face
uh from its knowledge of what it looks
like so if
you know if every picture of a face has
a mustache when it redraws the face it
draws them with mustaches
so theoretically we could do a thing
where
all the faces from like the left profile
is one person
then all the faces from the right
profile is a different person all the
faces from the front is another person
all the faces from like the bottom is
another person
and so you could you could theoretically
make it or make a deep fake that shifts
through faces depending on the
expressions and the angle of the face
that you're
like a super weird psychedelic fact
that'd be cool give a character sorry
a character with a multiple personality
disorder who
i don't know different face shapes
different emotions
for each emotion you have a different
face coming through it could be
that'd be interesting pretty wild yeah i
wonder if there's a little corridor
video we can do about somebody that gets
like
a psychic cursed cast on them that'd be
cool and it's like like
i said look at faces it just shifts
through like different people's face
yeah yeah that would actually be really
cool a really cool use of that
yeah okay well um i guess we'll do it at
some point
can we do one can we do a chord or crew
video where we use deep fakes to make
ourselves 10 out of 10 instead of
you know that's that's the other thing i
was thinking about is like
a big part of acting is just looking the
part and like there's a lot of people
who like
can perform really well but they don't
necessarily look the part that you need
from them like
that's why there's still so few like big
name actors out there because getting
somebody that
looks like henry cavill who can also act
like henry cavill
like you know i'm not not trying to rag
on him like he's not the greatest
actor in the world but he's not bad like
he's fine he's a he's a good actor but
like
getting people that can maintain both
those qualities it's very hard to find
and like so what if you just didn't have
to worry about how they looked
and you could just you know hire a model
grab their likeness and then throw it on
your actor because processing deep fakes
like
is really pretty painless once it's
trained like that's the thing even now
like i'm always so surprised at how
fast i just slap it onto footage and be
like oh it's good done
you know yeah you might lose something
in like the body though
because a lot like if you're just
i mean the actor who you're actually
capturing
with the footage would have to have
really good body
acting and physics acting as well well
that's where the performance
aspect comes in i mean there's a lot of
people who are good performers and but
there's not a lot of people who are good
performers
and have the exact look like i need a
model who is
also an academy award-winning actor it's
like oh good luck
it's also a bit of a bummer for that
actor who's like i was in this
triple-a title movie and nobody i don't
get any recognition for it nobody knows
my face yeah
if you think about it that's kind of
what like gary oldman and
you know uh andy circus have to go
through
i guess andy circus shouts from the
rooftop anytime
he's doing motion capture he's like this
is me
i am king kong it's like okay
you sure are buddy and he's done so many
at this point
yeah it's true it's like his calling
card yeah
there's that whole little snafu with him
wanting to get uh
basically an academy award for motion
capture performers
and then like all the animators kind of
pointed out it's like hey uh
we did like 60 like of the performance
in lord of the rings
he did like 40 and we did the rest of it
yeah that's what i'm quickly learning
with
uh mocap characters it's like i'm doing
a mocap character for this short film
i'm making
and i'll do the mocap but then sometimes
it's just like weirdly expressionless
even though the performance was
expressive and i have to go in and tweak
it and
change things and make it more
expressive on top of the mocap yeah
yeah i mean that's also when you're when
you're facing with like you're dealing
with a character in that piece that also
isn't you know you're it's a robot
mm-hmm so you know
a lot of times you need yeah no face you
need the
you need the body actions to be even
more expressive
right then than a human would might
which is kind of interesting because um
you can literally
on the like the x y plot graph of the
rotation of the bones you can literally
just like scale up the intensity and
then you take a performance that's like
this
into a performance that's like this
instantly it's just like
a performance like gain slider it's
pretty wild
that's funny yeah i mean motion capture
acting is such a collaborative effort
between like teams of people
which i mean in a way like regular
acting is too like the whole lot
the way like pop culture treats actors
versus like
how they actually function on set like
it's such a a mismatched world
you know well you know you take like
robert downey jr in the marvel movies
and like
granted he does carry you know scenes
on his shoulders but then once again
there's
writers telling him what to say there's
you know people lighting and shooting
him in certain ways there's vfx teams
going in and like
building his entire body around his face
or replacing his face too you know it's
like
there's there's makeup artists making
him look a certain way there's costume
designers making him look a certain way
there's audio engineers obviously
there's a team there but he's like the
guy at the front who executes
yeah and he has such an interesting
cadence you know what i'm saying like i
i totally get your point but i don't
know in
in like actors defenses like it's
you're you're in the moment executing
making
choices on the fly where almost every
every other role you just discussed
is like here's the plan hope it works
and then
he's that that's the actor you give the
plan to who then has to like
all right like now i have to make sure
this is
good how do i make sure this is actually
good though that's true and that's fair
but i think
it's still you know it's always still
worth acknowledging just
how much is happening around that
performance still
sure you almost have to not overreact
when you're an actor in that situation
because because that's
i don't know looking back on some of our
really older videos
and seeing some of our performances
in those ones and you know there's
there's this there's this immediate
tendency
when you're new to acting to to go oh
well there's all this stuff going on
i gotta i gotta really act you know i
gotta do things
and and that that immediately makes it
unnatural
well that's robert de niro's acting
advice somebody asked him
what to do and he was like just don't do
anything like that's literally what he
said is i just don't
do anything to be fair like
if you look the part and you sound the
part and the voice
is like such a huge part of acting that
like gets really understated
like i mean there's a reason why you can
still have like big name actors doing
the voices like you know having scarlett
johansson doing the computer voice in
her
like she's a very good voice actor and
like voice acting is like
i would argue almost like 70 percent of
a role of an actor is their voice
and then like and then you have how they
look and then you have the
plot construction around it and the
cinematography construction and
of course the soundtrack and so actual
performance is like such a small sliver
of like everything that actually falls
in place like visual performance like
good and putting expressions on your
face like yeah you're right like
as long as you say the lines
convincingly and you're just there in
front of the camera and we can see you
saying them
that's like that's most of the making
the movie and performing in it
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know it's pretty hard to
make those lines sound convincing
especially like
talking about robert downey jr i forget
what i was watching that he was in but i
was just like thinking about the
dialogue that he was saying like as if
it was written
on the screen i do that all the time
yeah and it's like this is not
great dialogue but he's saying it in
such an interesting way that you just
believe it
yeah i think that's i think that's the
biggest challenge for an actor is like
because so much of writing is like just
sloppily like here you go
it's like all right my line is like
today
is mankind's independence day it's like
okay
here we go here's the megaphone you're
giving the speech and now this is the
speech to save the world it's like
all right i'll do my best and then you
end up with like actually really good
lines that people remember
like may the force be with you like how
dumb would how dumb did that look on the
script before anybody said it
it looked so dumb but it's also
incredibly it's also incredibly close to
the
i don't know if he did this
intentionally but when catholics like
yeah in church
catholic mass and you you greet someone
you say um
god be with you yeah yeah and and it's
like very
very close to that i don't know if that
was intentional or not but
yeah that's whatever i hear made the
force be with you in my head there's the
echo of and also with you
right yeah no that's 100 intentional i'm
sure
so funny oh is peace be with you yeah
yeah yeah um that's so funny
uh sam speaking of acting you've been
doing something
that hasn't required any actors
well technically it required nico and
myself
to act in mocap pajamas but the three of
us
were there when it happened
when it went down yeah
some pretty crazy stuff went down um
sam any corn pajamas peter was capturing
it all some crazy stuff went down
yeah um yeah that's the whole thing
it's uh tell us about it
[Laughter]
well so okay so a year ago
um a year ago when gwen was born
um i had a lot of time in the middle of
the night and i
was playing video games and then i was
like i'm gonna get really productive
so i would start learning unreal engine
and basically i was like wow this is
cool like you can make cinematics with
this
and like this had all been inspired from
going to see the luck stages
like the volumes that they're now using
for the
you know mandalorian and stuff and
seeing how
these video game engine uh graphics were
being used for
like actual filmmaking was really
inspiring and so basically
um yeah we've been putting out all these
unreal videos all these mocap
experiments over the last year now
um stuff using specifically using unreal
engine
and now we're on our i think it's the
sixth
one that we've done there's there's
video game characters react
there was the local zero pitch project
um there was clint's vr meditation space
there was avatar two smoosh brewers
well yeah that would that's in there but
not necessarily a cinematic yeah and
then there's the handsome squidward
video and now we're on the sixth one
which is this video called the cut scene
which is going to be a court it's a
corridor video it's going to be a few
minutes long
and it's pretty sweet but it's also the
culmination of the last year of
you know figuring this stuff out and how
do you make convincing
cinematic narratives using unreal engine
and
because of all that work and effort put
into it um
you know i'm i'm kind of uh what is it
i'm not like anxious about it at this
stage but it's certainly there's a bit
of pressure
to kind of like succeed i guess
because everything else has been mired
with so much
jank from learning the process um yeah
so the through line in making this video
is that if it doesn't turn out well
then i'm gonna quit uh put your quick
corridor
and well maybe not quit corridor but i
am i'm never going to use
unreal engine ever again if i can't
finally make one video that i don't have
to like constantly apologize and make
excuses for
the entire time um it's time to give it
up
so it seems like it's going pretty well
because you wouldn't bet that
unless i think it's going well but yeah
you know we'll have to kind of
gauge that once it's done i mean based
on the stuff you've been
sending us it looks freaking sweet so
i'm excited i'm
yeah i think it's turning out pretty
decently too but it's
it's it's very it's complicated
and difficult because there's still not
a good collaborative workflow
for it in the sense that right now it's
mostly it's been me
pounding away on it since we shot it um
nico's made some environments for it
peter's made some uh
you made this like gunshot kind of code
thing that you can instead of like
placing a muzzle flash in after effects
when you're doing unreal you you trigger
a gun flat
a gun flash event basically that
makes a muzzle flash and a bullet hit
all at the same time
using the logic that a video game would
use to trace where somebody is shooting
exactly so so it's kind of like it's
it's a different
type of workflow but it's pretty sweet
and uh i've just been
plugging away it's it's getting close
it's getting really close i'm at the
like
i'm at the fine tuning pass where
basically you know you do motion capture
but there's still work to be done
afterwards where you need to make sure
sometimes people don't actually look at
each other when they're having a
conversation they have to tweak their
heads
you tweet you have to tweak their hands
so they hold their weapons a little bit
better
you know all these little tweaks like
that um
and that's where it's at at the moment
because
yeah peter did you have to write the
the the muzzle flash bullet hit
did you have to write that as code or
did unreal already have sort of presets
that you could apply
i mean all of the different chunks of it
are
little like nodes so the part where it
goes and traces a path out from the gun
and finds that spot and adds like a
bullet hit
it's like a line trace node that you put
in and then
yeah it's it's visual coding so it's not
like i'm actually typing
yeah it's blueprint based coding so yeah
you're basically making
nodes that connect to each other and
spit
information along like a path yeah right
um it's very approachable
yeah it's super approachable um yeah
so i guess yeah that's that's kind of
where things are at it's pretty cool
like the i mean it's fun doing mocap
but it's way more fun doing car chases
dude um
because you're not animating the cars
like you're doing in a normal like
3d scene where you're making like
keyframes and stuff like
you actually make you take drivable
vehicles
and then drive them with your keyboard
and so
like you get like this really kind of
like
i don't want to say natural because it's
like it's a video game but you get
but it kind of is natural motion in the
sense that compared to like a
a racing movie that's cg like pixar's
cars
or like speed racer or
whatever it's it's like the cars
actually are moving and reacting
so if you want them to do cool moves
you have to like get good at driving
these
like video game cars so it's like it's
like telling an expert gta player to
make a cool car chase i want you to do a
drift around this corner and then go off
this jump it's like
you actually have to hit them like the
future profession
is i'm a virtual stunt driver yeah well
seriously but that's what it is like
each
that that scene i made a scene of these
cars
all chasing each other there's four
vehicles in it
and i had to do
[Music]
i did about like 10 takes per vehicle
because it takes a while to get good
sometimes you do a jump and the car like
flips and
you have too much speed and so you slow
it down and
like i have one vehicle that had the
most the main vehicle
which is like the hero's suv that's
being chased was the the most difficult
one because i'm trying to have them
start off-road go off a jump hit the
main road and then like but
like fly off it's like going off of a
jump
and right when you land on the ground go
right into a drift that gets you onto
this main road
and so it's like you sit there trying to
like perfectly
land and then but one time once you're
on the road then you're like okay
i gotta hold like this perfect 60 mile
an hour speed now
and stay perfectly in this lane for like
30 seconds after i do it as well
in order to like get the full take
yes i mean i could stitch things
together but it's way easier when you
have long
unbroken takes it's also like your
imagination is no longer the limit
because you have so many variables
acting together that
like crazy random coincidences can
happen
that you never planned for like little
interesting physics things and i think
sliding into each other
i like how my imagination is not like
what's at stake here
like you know what i mean like it
whereas yeah yeah you're like all right
here's the scene here's the cars like
only so many things
can happen you know you set constraints
for yourself
basically by doing it so you just try
and make the best of
what you got even the camera angles then
afterwards you're like well this is how
the cars
all kind of it's like it's like it's
like getting a bunch of stunt drivers to
do a sweet action sequence
and you're not filming it as it's
happening
you're finding the best angles of that
scene afterwards
which is actually way nicer and way
easier
than you know like i'm imagining like
all the experiences i had filming with
vehicles
where you're like all right here's the
shots we want to get one from the front
one from the side
one in this thing one in the driver's
seat one in the passenger you know
like you try and predict what the shots
are going to look like and orchestrate
it as best as possible
but very frequently when you're doing it
you don't realize
oh the best angle was back there or
sometimes you do realize that
and there's nothing you can do like
maybe you try and steal it at the end of
your shoot
but this this allows you to
kind of get the get the best shots of
your scene
even if you don't immediately think of
them in the moment
do you think the uh the pinnacle do you
think we'll reach the
the it point with this style of uh
storytelling
when we can successfully go in and
reinvent live action scenes that were
already done
with by changing the ending or like
changing something that happens
within that scene because there was
always a motivation
when we were doing live action stuff to
go
hey this is gta real gta
mm-hmm i mean we're arguably not that
far away from being able to take
video of like a moment and just giving
you the computer then being able to
re-render that moment from
any other angle like yeah there's a
crazy papers coming up yeah there's a
paper coming out where they basically
kind of did that and like you know
they're granted there's limitations and
whatnot but like
yeah we're getting to the point where
it's like we can just film a scene maybe
film it from like you know
eight different angles just cover with
as many cameras as you can and just give
it to the computer and then
now go in and pick your camera angle
after the fact well
that's already here there was a
volumetric video shot like the warner
brothers
or universal lot on like a western town
that they released
that it was like a full 3d video of all
these actors and horses doing this crazy
thing we started
us out to like go film a video there and
we just i was too busy and we're just
crap what do we do oh boy
when this is like this was last year
last summer to be fair like when those
kind of opportunities come up as cool as
they are
there's an aspect of like i'd like to
but at the end of the day i'm just gonna
be looking at something cool and be like
cool yeah sometimes it's cool
no it was just to go there i know but at
this point it's just like you should
have just gone there and like talked
did a podcast hey guys what's up uh
we're uh they're doing a volume metric
video but uh we're gonna do the corridor
cast
so um it'll be going on in the
background
you know you've watched it you can watch
this video from any angle volumetric
podcast
it's a thousand terabytes
yeah no but that's it's the place was
like 2 000 square feet or something huge
the way you do your podcast than the
volume is everyone goes to like crazy
different locations and then just like
hops on discord like this
and you're like look there's sam talking
in the second story of the saloon
oh there's nico he's near the well over
here
wait so how does how how do they what
kind of cameras do they use to capture
like a
like a full environment like that and
then pick the angle a million
a million a lot of cameras and then ai
guessing what's in between the angles
and then
and then taking that and doing like a
photogrammetry thing i
honestly have no idea how to do it yeah
it's a point it's like point cloud-based
or something
yeah nico what do you think
as resident ai expert well
uh have any of you guys seen the new
papers where they can do like
novel angles of something if somebody
gets a bunch of pictures of something
and that's not even 3d models that's
just
fully ai generated it's a fully ai
generated image that's the weird thing
because it seems like it'd be a 3d model
and it must be kind of weird to work
with because you don't have a 3d model
yeah you don't have a viewport
yeah you just kind of say it give me
this angle and i give it to you it's
like oh that's pretty good
the crazy thing is that like it does
reflections and transparency and
everything correctly because it's it's
literally just interpolating between
pictures
so it's just like a computer going like
well here's a picture close to that
angle and here's another picture close
to that angle from the other side and
i'll just kind of
guess what the picture between them
would look like
it's like film minority report it's it's
it is actually
creating scenes in between footage and
art
arguably this is a more efficient way of
like like let's say you want to like
watch like a vr video like the problem
with 3d video
is that if you tilt your head at all so
your eyes are no longer exactly
horizontal
well the scene stops being 3d uh and you
also can't like move around i mean
they have volumetric video now where
it's like using a whole like spherical
capture
but basically the way it's working is
it's just there's like you know a
thousand different video feeds and it's
just playing different video feeds as
your head moves around
uh you know so it's not exactly the most
practical solution but like
if you could just provide a scene that's
like
i don't know you just provide a single
like feed of a scene and just have the
ai
like re-interpolate basically doing like
the space warp that they already kind of
do
yeah uh when like your framerate skip
and vr like that gives you true
volumetric video without the overhead
cost
i mean yeah there's a vr or demo they
released for that tech
where you can go into completely photo
real scenes rendered from every angle
wow perfect crazy well there you go
just go to two minute papers youtube
channel there's a recent video on that
yeah this is crazy i just you know what
vr is cool
i'm really looking forward to some
augmented reality goggles like
it's you know it's fun running around
like slicing zombies but i want to go
out into the actual street
and see the zombies in the actual street
and like feel the pavement under my feet
as i run
you know along wielding my virtual
katana peter what made you think of this
sprinting vr game
because and i'll let you explain what
this is
but it involves wearing a vr headset and
running as fast as you can
i mean the whole pitch is just the name
which is
full sprint vr and it's the the game is
like
just a leaderboard
can we just please make this video like
please like let's just take a vr headset
go out into a street you know like
obviously you'll be able to see through
we can make a pitch
let's make a pitch video for it no you
can't
go through it it's only grid lines on
the floor
yeah let's make like a fake kickstarter
for this game i was thinking about
releasing it but it's so dangerous
a quick draft of full sprint vr and
great because the thing is
that it's excellent it's like you would
have to be on the quest
yeah or you couldn't do it with a wired
headset i mean unless people like are
real
it's like you could do overalls like
if you're wired like you can do like
there's a one map which is like
like a 20-foot sprint like
who can get the height top speed
within 20 feet
[Laughter]
is like the full unlock one that has
like the thousand meter
oh my god yeah you have to come up with
a lot of anti-cheating stuff because
people just throw their headsets
they would put it like on like yeah a
wheel like they'd
put it on like a slingshot on like
casters
and like like well you could record
video at the same time so the top
uh 20 uh on the leaderboard are always
being vetted
uh by a person maybe it requires foot
trackers
just make sure like the hands are like
in the appropriate zone in front of the
headset
that means you have to throw all three
of them at the same time i think it
could be possible
yeah you just have the hands have to
like stay in this general area and
go like that i mean you could just have
a leaderboard open for non-sprinting
challenges like who can make their
headset move through a 20-foot space the
fastest
without breaking it no i think it's easy
to detect if someone's actually running
or not or just
throwing the headset i mean we could
never
but we could leak it leak it under a
fake account
yeah that's how you do it it's like we
couldn't read lisa says too dangerous
and you
leak it and there you go and there's no
evidence
well i just it's we thought of this
beforehand it's just ah man
it's like one of those things where you
realize that the real world version
is like kind of superior
it's like one of these vr games that
doesn't need to exist oh i could
actually just run it
just run normally well no it's like tide
pods
it's like it's so stupid nobody
everybody thinks it's funny but nobody's
actually doing it but there are actually
people who are doing it and eating tide
pods
and running full sprint in vr
because i remember you mentioning it and
i cut in the discord and i i
commented i was like wow the idea of
using real world
space to govern speed speed and distance
is terrifying
and then i was like and i was like wait
that's just like normally running
you're using real world scale to gauge
your distance and speed
[Music]
full sprint vr let's do it sorry i'm
just i'm just writing the script right
now
man it'd have to be an oculus quest
just like grid lines on the floor and
like a big leader board on the side and
that's the whole game
like the thing is that like you have to
where we shoot it but like
no we always like we're trying to
advertise it so it's like
you want you know how like whenever you
watch a like a vr
game trailer there's always like cool
shots of the person wearing the headset
like
pretend yeah which is hilarious because
like i get
no i know it's a vr game i know i'm
gonna look like that like i know i'm
gonna look stupid
like you don't need to like sell me on
how stupid i'm gonna look
like just show me the gameplay like yeah
did it always bugs me when they show
that stuff in vr trailers
it's also like that's the most
inefficient way to play a like a vr game
like
like in population one you know they're
sniping but the easiest way to snipe in
the game is just to put your hands down
at waist level and tuck them in so that
they don't shake at all and you just
snipe like this is like actually trying
to like hold an imaginary gun up
yeah in front of your face it's so funny
yeah
oh gosh when i so obviously this last
week and a half here everyone got
vaccines slash
at the got covered yeah and so i like i
had my quest
like and oh my god there's so many bad
quest games
i know in fact i think most of them are
like like 99
right yeah right for good games the
problem is like you can't just
phone in the same old gameplay in vr
which you can in real life like there
are so many games that are retreading
the same
old gameplay loop from like games from
20 years ago and there's so few games
actually trying to innovate and try new
game design ideas
like and you just when you play vr it's
like oh yeah point at the box and shoot
it cool target practice great
haha you dressed up some graphics still
boring
i shot at targets once 10 years ago and
i got tired of it
i haven't had the urge to do it since
it's all about the vibes
yeah it's all about cool gameplay ideas
it's like
brandon put it well when he's talking
about uh bone works where it's like
vr should be giving you super powers it
shouldn't vr should be about
wow you have the same basic [ __ ]
skeleton issues in
vr that you do in the real world like no
it should be like i can fly in vr i have
force powers in vr and i'm super strong
in vr like
it's supposed to be fantasy escape not
aha you still have to bend down and pick
[ __ ] up it's like
screw that you freaking told me about
saints and sinners the walking dead game
who gets real so tired they die
after sprinting for like 20 feet that
game is
so annoying you're like literally
running
for like 10 seconds and you're like
[Laughter]
well maybe they weren't in shape and at
the beginning of the game you're
actually just really out of shape
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah today marks the day that
uh
everybody in the studio has cleared
their two weeks for the vaccines
so every yeah everybody here has either
been vaccinated
or recently gotten coveted or both well
technically
tomorrow is my vaccine birthday but
whatever yeah that's okay so yeah
uh we don't actually have to wear masks
here anymore and i'm
bet i bet i'm gonna get comments saying
otherwise but when everybody's
vaccinated and they're all in the same
place together
yep that's it i mean what what are the
comments gonna be it's like what's the
point
what's the point of getting a vaccine
if you're not to wear your mask
afterwards like
it's if you're just saying like i might
as well have just not gotten the vaccine
yeah if i'm going to pretend like i'm
still going to get it i still wear masks
when i go out in public or you know
yeah like i'm not going to be i'm going
into every convenience store
you're going to give them a really good
feedback and then they'll be like
show me your apple wallet and i'll be
like
they'll be like this and they're like
this is meaning like this this is a
non-standardized
like id card from some random healthcare
how are we supposed to track this sir
dude how the hell is that gonna work
it's they're not gonna do it
like why even bother why even bother
putting a system in place and literally
in like
one month to two months everybody who
wants a vaccine well god true it's like
you reach
uh critical mass with vaccines and hey
if you're listening to this
go out and get your shot do your part
yeah it doesn't suck
that night at all yeah you'll feel
better
the night of mm-hmm no seriously go out
and get your shot yeah
don't be that person and then prepare to
feel sick for the next 24 hours
and then it will be over enjoy netflix
take it take a day off work
and they just they officially just
announced that like part of that huge
um like coveted relief bill that they're
doing paid time off
for people who get vaccines well great
and the government will give any
company basically that's under 500
employees
credit for any employees that go out
and do that that's cool wonderful i'm
just going to i'm just going to pat
ourselves in the back because we
actually made it a company policy that
you get your day off and you got your
vaccine
yeah before the government said that
yeah
we just figured that'd be the right
thing to do i feel like yeah people can
just do that
you know like it's like i mean you guys
are good bosses
thanks peter it was very fair and uh
considerate so we basically i'm just
saying we have to get that credit
jake nobody said this to the us
government
i don't know yeah well you know what
nine of people are
doing the government it's the government
like you love them
i don't understand why it's like you
need to here's like why do we need to
take money from them for stuff that
people should just be doing or not
doesn't just like
why just buy the whole thing look we're
just getting a little bit of our taxes
back that's all it is
yeah yeah people are struggling people
are having a hard time
getting that back man they sent me a
letter i had to do an amended return so
i'm just going to go on a quick rant
all right and um
so whatever it's amended return it's
like not a big deal right but
you you file and you say hey this was
this okay whatever
you file it the accountants filed it but
then because they're so far behind right
now
with everything that happened with covet
and now all these new bills and all this
spending and all these tax deferments
and like all this crazy stuff that's
happened in the last 18 months
they are so far behind that they got
my original return and then guess what
their automated system sends you
sends you a bill right when it's like
wait
you had a return that said this but this
is what you this is what we have
and then so it automatically sends you a
bill for the tax that it thinks you owe
and then and then the amended return
comes in but the system is so far behind
that it doesn't catch up and so then
what you have to do is what the best
thing you should do
should do is pay your pay the tax on the
money that you don't owe
so that eventually the following year or
whatever it is later when they catch up
they can pay you back i don't know but
but meanwhile
they charge interest on that money the
entire time
and then they just give you back what
they
what you didn't owe them to begin with
oh my god
it's like it's like guys godly guys
anyways it's frustrating we should just
go full digital
countries have done it you know it's
working for people
yeah but you know what i know that's it
that's
i'm that's it you're right you're right
there could be improvements across the
board for everything peter
oh yeah yes
best way to look at it always see the
silver lining i don't envy
the people there under the mountains of
paperwork at the irs trying to work no
totally certainly not i'm not blaming
those people at all i did get audited
one time in my past and the guy that
audited me was actually
really nice he was very straightforward
his name was easy to work with
and it was like look i brought i did my
part i brought my
like returns and i brought everything
that i had and we've looked through it
and it was like
it was like two hours and that was it
and we were done
that's nice and actually i felt better
about the irs
after that than than than i do
than i did before if you can believe
that even i guess they just they're like
you're you're in i'm gonna audit you and
you're like what for he's like i think
you need another hug
yeah yeah we hugged it out that was it
yeah yeah
yeah that's why people tuning in to the
corridor
podcast talking about taxes
taxes guys do you guys want to hear
about get into some weird [ __ ] i'll run
define weird [ __ ] i mean stuff like that
you know
i don't know if people are interested in
that but i certainly
dude there's something i want to talk
about which is um
freaking joe rogan loves the guy he put
a
a video on his instagram of this like
ufo
footage that had been released by like
the pentagon
or something and it's like if you look
at the video it's like yeah there's this
triangle thing in the sky it's going and
it's blinking
and by the way the government confirmed
or they
i don't know if they confirmed it was
aliens but they like authorized the
footage or whatever but anyways
you look at all the other stars and it's
like oh they're triangles too
it's like this [ __ ] who released
this video put a triangle cut out in
front of his camera sensor
and so everything turned into triangles
and everybody's like oh my gosh
but it's just out of focus footage do
you know those people that think that
lens flares are energy like sprites
yeah in their footage unfortunately
that's a lot of the comments in that
post were
were saying hey this is a camera
technique
yeah so actually that's actually an idea
i had for a quarter
crew video i think we should take a
bunch of classic like
unsolved mystery videos like we can
either do a bunch in a video we can do
like you know one that's focused just on
ghosts ones that focus just on ufos
and we should go through all of our
tools and and actually enhance the
footage
like they do on like a cop show yeah and
like actually use ai to actually enhance
like the yeti film
or you know the pictures of the loch
ness monster and like see
if we can actually like provide like you
know because if people are going there
and using the ai to upscale like here's
you know the 1890s in 4k
with color and it's like let's do the
same thing with some cool like ghost
footage that would be cool
yeah what about yeti's in 4k with color
yeah what about
that well you know who we would
d in here we would have to get captain d
in here yeah yetis in 4k with color
i would click on that yeti yeti's
remastered in fork
in hdr4k oh my gosh
i'm gonna say this here so that everyone
here specifically knows but i'm just
saying
as part of that we should make one clip
oh
that we pretend is like a clip we found
and it happens to be the best one that
would be fun and we're like
wait a minute this is real like we've
already because we made it to like trick
ourselves you know trick people
based on all the techniques we're using
that's a
you know there's a streak there's a
little mischievous corridor streak no i
know we do
we just go and film our own custom yeti
shot
see i like i like the yeti because like
the yeti's such like an implausible
monster
what do you mean it's just a freaking
hairy mammal that's bipedal
well exactly there's no monkey there's
no like there's no bipedal monkeys
walking around in the sierras like
we know that for a fact like for the for
them to even
live through like a generation they need
to be like
procreating because they're really
emotional why is nico
yeah that's what they want you this time
they hear a satellite taking a
satellite image they hide yeah like
there's a whole like evolutionary chain
of how creatures develop like
it it's like you think it's canon you're
right you're right
yetis are real but that's that's why
actually that's why yeti is my favorite
because it's the most implausible and in
a way
the most unimaginative monster
but the best part is like you get some
good yeti yells once in a while you're
out in the mountains and you're in the
distance like
i make it a point to get one yeti yell
out
every time i go hike just to make sure
yeah people
think the legend's alive that's great so
there's a great all gas no brakes video
where he goes and hangs out with like
people trying to find bigfoot
i actually just picked up a book called
uh there's a radio station called the
desert oracle
i guess and it's basically just a bunch
of like desert conspiracy theories dude
my brother loves that radio station
yeah so there's a book where they just
did a compilation of like their best
stories oh cool
and i'm reading through it and it's like
it's actually great it's really well
written but the beginning just like the
first chapter is on how not to die in
the desert and look like a dumb tourist
it's like here's the things you don't do
to be an idiot interesting
and then it just goes on from there like
there's so many good stories
nico in your estimate and your expert
conspiracy opinion
what is the most plausible conspiracy
thing conspiracy
um are we talking creature based
conspiracy yeah yeah
creativity jfk we need to eat or drink
we're just addicted to food and water
let's see there's a couple um what i
already mentioned on this podcast which
is
there's a theory that uh uh yuri gagarin
i can't remember if that's how his name
is pronounced was not actually the first
man in space
uh that russia actually launched
multiple astronaut cosmonauts into space
who did not survive
and so they kept that under wraps that's
like that's like that fits into every
russian 50s and there's a there's a pair
of italian
amateur radio operators that record or
recorded distress calls and something
like it's getting hot i can't hold it
it's getting on
ah and then like based on triangulating
like oh that person would have been in
space
traveling above us like yeah so that
one's
that one's a good one that's a spicy one
yeah that's not a monster that's not a
creature base are you looking for a
creature one
oh okay uh my brother saw a freaking
lizard creature in louisiana
apparently there's
it was a big iguana i mean there's not a
lot of good creature
myths like there's a loch ness monsters
we're just brushing that off
but yeah yeah he saw lizardman what okay
yeah he was like a man
no my brother uh was on tour with his
band driving through
the south and he looked out the window
of his tour bus everybody was sleeping
except him and his friend
and he saw like this freaking big
lizard guy there's actually like a lot
of drawings of this creature on the
internet and stuff just like
standing yeah look up oh freaking he's
it's a swamp
man yeah it's like a swamp have you
heard the legends of the black dog
the black dog the black dog oh the thing
that like tore up cars no this is a
well i guess you could say that it's
more it's a it's a trucker thing
so if you're driving late at night and
you see how the corner your eye looks
like a black dog running along the side
of the road at the speed of your car
and you look over you try to see that
and you can't see it it's gone but you
look back forwards onto the road and
then on the corner you see the black dog
running alongside the car again
that's the sign that you worry about to
pass out and fall asleep at the wheel
it's the black dogs trying to race you
whoa and if it beats you
you're gonna crash interesting so when
you see the black dog you pull over and
you get some sleep
well that's like actually kind of nice
yeah
it's a little like it's like a little
like sleep demon that's like
chasing you and if it catches you and
you fall asleep at the wheel yeah
some images here peter of uh lizardman
mm-hmm south carolina's lizard man yeah
yeah that's probably it
this looks like a man in a costume i'm
not gonna lie yeah a reincarnation
jake not the real of course it's a man
i mean yeah my brother is like it could
have been a dude in like
an incredibly life like hollywood
costume standing by this lake with his
back to us
like like eight feet tall with it's
probably just like a cool like
thing that somebody put up with it could
have been get people like your brother
go like whoa was that the lizard man
totally it could have been i would do
stuff like that
i'm down yeah if anything if anywhere
that would happen it would be in the
south for sure
yeah i want to believe i guess the black
dog is my favorite like
plausible conspiracy theory animal demon
thing i mean it's just
it's just your eyes peripheral vision
playing tricks on you when you're tired
yeah like your headlights
on the grass coming in going by you know
would probably
look like that well did you know our
peripheral vision in terms of uh motion
clarity and spatial clarity is just as
good as the center of our vision
so like i can throw a ball to you you
can catch it just as well like not
looking at it just how to clean your
eyes you can looking at it
because your spatial awareness is even
across your whole field of view
roughly and so like you see when you see
things moving on the corner of your eyes
like
your eyes can pick that up just as well
as i can if you're looking at it but
it's your whole sleep deprivation
causing it to
trigger interesting when you're driving
down the highway
so yeah well
gentlemen that's uh that's what we know
so we know yeah so we'll do a we're
going to go on a yeti hunt we'll let you
know what we find
okay i seriously think we should do um
we should do full sprint vr though
yes it'd be super easy to shoot it'd be
super funny
mm-hmm remember that eraser really funny
visual effects
we were like the presidential fitness
test like you did like two erasers that
were like
10 meters away and you like run and grab
them and run back like you did like a
tennis court
so the where it had the tape of it going
like and then you have to run to the
other side of the court and baby you
gotta run back
oh did they update the technology for
your i guess so
yeah i mean he was on the contract
racers and set them up
one side
yeah we all it straight into had airpods
you got a gym teacher with a stopwatch
yeah did you have to do the presidential
fitness yeah okay still doing it huh oh
yeah did you
did you get a signed plaque from the
president uh
no i was very subpar jake did you
pass your presidential fitness i mean
yes i did
did you get the signed plaque from bill
clinton uh
i think they sent us a letter right well
not a plaque it's more like a
it's like a diploma yeah because the
ones that actually like
achieved the presidential fitness thing
got like you know it wasn't actually
signed but it was like a signature
reproduction on like little things
saying congratulations you're
you're the one we'll call upon when the
wars break out
we'll keep you on record here in the
selective service
yeah no i yeah i my brother actually
was that was like his thing for a while
he him and his buddies were trying to
outdo each other in the presidential
fitness
what a healthy competition yeah
literally
it was pretty funny and the hardest one
was the stretching for me
oh yeah that was the worst did you guys
have those blue
uh aluminum boxes that you had to put
your feet on and then reach like that
yeah oh yeah yeah that's what kept me
from getting my
abraham lincoln certificate kept me from
speeding it for being in
man i literally don't know what you guys
are talking about
i went to like bayport which is like an
artsy fight scene like
i went to stone bridge the stone bridge
that's the one yeah yeah there was no
rules there i spent all of sixth grade
taking the same class all day over and
over sam's not kidding
it was very much like a free form yeah
they're like choose your own classes and
i'm like
drawing computers drawing computers
drawing computers
that's my day and they're like great
and arguably it worked out yeah
everything else
sam i didn't know you were a stonebridge
kid that that that makes a lot of stuff
stoner
bridge despite being in sixth grade
stoner bridge yeah
let's do it keep rolling man
[Music]
don't stop keep rolling roll and roll
come on
all right croutons keep rolling heck
yeah and this is the part where we
actually stop
rolling a rolling crouton
gathers no moss